LEDs tucked into tires for instance or a
bike helmet with indicators or even a
digital anti-theft device smart bikes
have plenty of innovative features that
users can control on the display or via
a phone app online marketing consultant
funk agamous and doesn't need a key to
unlock his bike just his phone he's had
a smart bike for about a year now
yes had some clients unfucked Ozaki
smile there's a fun factor when you go
to buy bread or ice cream for example
nice mothers have to find their keys
whereas all I have to do is get my phone
out can unlock the bike or turn on the
lights that sort of stuff it was a huge
potential is this bike smartphone combo
a winner or will cyclists remain loyal
to their analog 2 wheelers the by
journalist David course month thinks
cyclists will go for the gimmicks
socata neva cool there's a gold rush
fever at the moment when you look at the
crowdfunding campaigns the startups the
gadgets that are being developed there
are so many options and we'll see which
ones actually established themselves and
I think it has a lot to do with how
society is developing and the way people
are using data acquisition devices so I
should that apostles creator
I'm homeless magazine nuts and one
there's certainly a high demand for
gadgets and apps like the bike citizens
especially for urban cyclists it favors
cycle paths and side streets the app
also wants to influence City Planning by
evaluating data to improve the
infrastructure this helps to create what
are known as heat maps which show
frequently traveled routes I know that
there is a Data Protection issue
companies collecting data have to ensure
its secure and their database is being
hacked into an information being put
online the information that's gathered
the mobility behavior can also be used
by bike thieves the Crematory often
fatigue millets them which could be a
coup because smart bikes go for around
ten thousand euros but a stolen smart
bike can be easily located thanks to
inbuilt tracking technology that's what
the bike maker Vaughn wolf uses dustless
I my design
this is the page we can use to find the
bikes again it's connected to the bike
via GMs tracking and it's visible here
on the screen directly often we can just
see where the bike was at any given
moment in time side corner as whew
Wow but in practice it's perhaps a
little more adventurous than all this a
team from van Wolff tracked one stolen
bike from Paris France to Casablanca in
Morocco they zigzagged around the city
in a taxi equipped with their tracker
and they did find the stolen bike in a
garage but the Moroccan authorities
stopped them from bringing it back fans
think the data collection has its
advantages
some smart bike users don't mind being
under surveillance
the miners let's give huh be talking a
bit dangerous I'm not worried at all it
isn't anyone who wants my data can have
it Demi how's anyone who wants to spy on
me or get into my bike app will always
find a way so busy and I prefer to
concentrate on the advantages and all
the options for playing around there's
plenty in store for the fans of smart
bikes and gadgets however nobody expects
the wheel to be reinvented
you